はいみなさん方水浴どれ一つなんか色んな自販機があると思うんですよお菓子ってが
出るじゃない決まればカップ麺が売ってる自販機とか食べ物が出るじゃないとは
いろんな寿司アンケがあると思うんですけどね家の近くの山のてっぺんあたりにすげー
自販機あるという情報を入れましたな
是非チャンネル自己紹介自己紹介と思うんだどうも初めましてとってばそのちょっと不
明確なのでその辺まで来るまでペアと言ってみましょう
[音楽]
大変お待たせしました約1か月だったんですよ
iphone x 届きましたいかにもすっかり晴れとドイツってしまえば後々もない
みたいなところだったら
子も右だ組空爆にマルチビタミンの米欧組なって4日社内
ね待って予選版6レイズよいい彼曲いいからよこせは待ってください青ですよ
あああ
マルチビタミンの栄養軍はを8日社内
ねまつや旋盤6レースよああどうかいいから横線を迎え曲いいからよこせは待って
ください青ですよ
まあを住山ピッチの多くにその雀鬼あるという情報を痛めたけど場所がほんとわかん
ないちょっとピザグレード下がっさえます2打目に
これがケースてる学校ですめっちゃ奥まで行きましたらこのまま
どんな切っ月を持つにあるんだそんなとかじゃなきゃあるんですねあんらしい
今本ずつごとにですよもうわけわかんないどこ小部屋骨所ココ2パダ打ったのかすみ
ませんですよ
わけわからないどこ編骨
どこ自分に聞かれましても得るステッパー固まっちゃうを2羽がだうってのかすみませ
んですねああああすげえまだまだ続きますよこれ怖いですねはい
ずばたたったった不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不建てたとタブー
+ず不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不やせ
ん
ウバパックあった不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
たず不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不らしいでし
た
偶然なくおっしゃるこれ何て歌ってますねやばい気が一番堂3-6立ってるよね見て
ぽくなってます
ちょっとも取りすぎたんでもう1回上に登ります今度家まで来たの初めて
たぶんここで国語
メモリアル母という
あってでんえんやっけ
ここじゃに
小菅ない道だけですねいつだけ果たしてこんなところに本当にそんな特殊な自販機が
あるのでしょうか
特殊なじゃあ切らないよっていうのを知らないんですよ
あの実はですね
での中身のドリンクがー
ずロード超えてるみたいなずつ集めたいですよいやもうマイナスでマイナス何度みたい
な世界のこと以上にそれプラスいいんだよ
そんなものがあるのですらしいんだよ珍しいからちょっと気になっちゃって
あここぜねなんかここらへんぽいぬまた v ラインが多分ここに特殊の自販機がある
ということで早速行ってみましょう
7じゃあここで待ってなさい私が買って産ませてあげようありがとうございます
ない買ってこい図って帰っへいかという
まあ結構ありますねこんなんだよ社会観から来ました
あっ
[音楽]
んじゃう
待って待って待って待って待って待って待ってん
絶対あれだあれ自然体あるな
まずあっ
あれもあるだろう
あれですね絶対コレだてなんならこれ別にさあここの自販機じゃなくてもありそうじゃ
ねじゃんって普通こんな別にある山こうやって上に列の半分なく室ぐらいのコンテンツ
力ですかね私がマイナス事って書いてあるよ
とかよみんなことなくねこれ見たことないんです家の近くでもないしです4-事で出て
くるって
ね待って待ってやっぱってやっぱれ
[音楽]
準備中だってそうしても買えないということを振り綺麗ではないってことでしょ
ドデカミンなのかどういうこと準備釣ったところで売り切りだったさあ超えて出るぞ
できるってこれに入れた準備中ですから待ってれば着くのかもしれない冷やしてる途中
なんですかね
たぶんそうだかもマイナスことでも普通のじゃんけどなかなかたどり着けないといけど
カマーチョ今冷やしてて準備中なんだと思います
絶対そうだよ
なんだイェイなるにゃんからねとけどちょっと準備中でなくなるまで待ちます
なんだよね voodoo ん
[音楽]
tan
me
teal
ana あああっ